men always want to be a woman's first
love
women like to be a man's last romance
we live in an age when unnecessary
things
are our only necessities
always forgive your enemies
because nothing annoys them so much
truth indeed
is a thing that is most painful to
listen to
and most painful to utter
we are all in the gutter
but some of us are looking at the stars
true friends
stab you in the front
be yourself
everyone else is already taken
the one charm of the past is that it is
in the past
most people are other people
their thoughts are someone else's
opinions
their lives a mimicry
their passions a quotation
only the shallow know themselves
women are meant to be loved
not to be understood
the only difference between the saint
and the sinner is that every saint has a
past and every sinner has a future
the terror of society
which is the basis of morals the terror
of god which is the secret of religion
these are the two things that govern us
experience is one thing you can't get
for nothing
to get back to one's youth
one has merely to repeat one's follies
experience is merely the name men gave
to their mistakes
each man lived his own life
and paid his own price for living it
nowadays people know the price of
everything and the value of nothing
you can never be overdressed or
overeducated
anyone who lives within their means
suffers from a lack of imagination
i can resist everything except
temptation
crying is for plain women
pretty women go shopping
suddenly at some moment in our lives we
understand that we are no longer the
actors
but the spectators
when one is in love one always begins by
deceiving oneself
and one always ends by deceiving others
that is what the world calls
a romance
the truth is merely pure and never
simple
anybody can sympathize with the
sufferings of a friend
but it requires a very fine nature to
sympathize with a friend's success
if men married the women we deserved
we would have a very bad time of it
a man's face is his autobiography
a woman's face
is her work of fiction
i like men who have a future and women
who have a past
to love oneself is the beginning of a
lifelong romance
i choose my friends for their good looks
my acquaintances for their good
characters
and my enemies for their good intellects
the harmony of the soul and body
how much that is
we in our madness have separated the two
and have invented a realism that is
vulgar
an ideality that is void
ridicule the tribute paid to the genius
by the mediocrities
men marry because they are tired
women because they are curious
both
are disappointed
between men and women there is no
friendship possible
there is passion
enmity worship love
but no friendship
you don't love someone for their looks
or their clothes or their fancy car
but because they sing a song only you
can
hear everything in moderation
including moderation
you will always be loved and you will
always be in love with love
a grand passion is the privilege of
people who have nothing to do
man is least himself when he talks in
his own person
give him a mask and he will tell you the
truth
the basis of every scandal is an immoral
certainty
you are not young enough to know
everything
when i was young
i thought that money was the most
important thing in life
now that i am old
i know that it is
there is only one thing in life worse
than being talked about
and that is not
being talked about
one can always be kind people about whom
one cares nothing
the very essence of romance
is uncertainty
if a man treats life artistically
his brain
is his heart
if you wish to understand others
you must intensify your own
individualism
all women become like their mothers
that is their tragedy
no man does
that's his
[Music]
the form of government that is most
suitable to the artist
is no government at all
ordinary riches can be stolen
real riches cannot
and your soul are infinitely precious
things
that cannot be taken from you
to become the spectator of one's own
life
is to escape the suffering of life
the only reason one should never marry
is because one should always be in love
live the wonderful life
that is in you
let nothing be lost upon you
be always searching for new sensations
be afraid of nothing
art is the most intense mode of
individualism that the world has
known sooner or later we have to pay for
what we do
making a useful thing
as long as he does not admire it
the only excuse for making a useless
thing is that one admires it intensely
to get into the best society
one has either to feed people
amuse people or shock people
the past is what man should not have
been
the present is what man ought not to be
the future is what artists are
the old believe everything
the middle aged suspect everything
the young know everything
nothing should be out of the reach of
hope
life is hope
the true mystery of the world
is the visible
not the invisible
it is a curious fact that people are
never so trivial as when they take
themselves seriously
one should never trust a woman who
speaks of a real age
a woman who would tell one that
would tell one everything
journalism is unreadable
and literature is unread
only love can keep anyone alive
the world is divided into two classes
those who believe the incredible
and those who do the improbable
leave us some unreality do not make us
too offensively sane
to test reality
we must see it on the tightrope
when the veritas become acrobats
we can judge them